why stop at one hero
when we can show you all of them
heroes are forged in darkness defined by
sacrifice
there is still hope
for the multiverse
here we go
we do not back down from a fight
aye aye
commander now or never
zombies great idea
that doesn't sound ominous at all
hey
who needs a plan
i have a shield
what happened to you you will see
witness the biggest heroes of the
multiverse
or small if you catch my drift
what if you know what they say when
you're out of luck always go duck i'm
pretty sure no one says that now
streaming
only on disney plus
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
will be my marvel what if episode 9
finale trailer video the multiverse
avengers teaming up to fight ultron with
all six infinity stones so everyone
press f to pay respects to the
multiverse if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos i will be doing hawkeye
episodes after this and i'll be doing
videos for what if season two which
sounds like it's going to premiere next
year based on their plans but there were
a lot of questions about what was
happening at the end of episode 8 with
ultron and all six infinity stones going
into different universes and the
infinity stones still working i'll
answer what's going on with that also
what's going on with all the different
characters from the episodes coming back
to team up in this multiverse avengers
team or exiles if you're a big comic
book fan it's the same concept a bunch
of characters from different universes
forming their own team all the
merchandise that they're selling for the
what if all the toys and stuff just bill
them as the guardians of the multiverse
so i think that's what they're going to
be calling them in the future seasons of
the show but as i said probably the
biggest comment that i saw in my what if
episode 8 video was why did ultron's
infinity stones work outside the normal
mcu dimension inside the watcher's space
that exists between the different
universes the multiverse and why did his
infinity stones work when they started
to punch each other through the
different universes because if you're a
long-time comic book reader and you
watch the loki series for the most part
the infinity stones become useless
outside of the universe that they came
from the main reason why marvel did that
in the past like there's an important
reason why infinity stones aren't
supposed to work outside of their own
universe is because if infinity stones
from any universe worked then that would
completely break the story anybody could
use the space stone for example to
travel into alternate reality and
assemble another infinity gauntlet right
after avengers end game and marvel
doesn't want everybody and their sister
to be wielding an infinity gauntlet
right after they just got done with the
infinity saga that was what the whole
joke on loki was also meant to be about
like it was meant to be a cool twist to
show you how powerful the tva seemed how
powerful kang seemed just to make loki
frightened because he seemed so sure of
himself but the joke about them not
working them being used as paperweights
in the tva was also kind of meant to
wink from behind the camera with the
writers and kevin feige the marvel
producers saying these infinity stones
they're not going to be a big plot
device going forward into marvel phase
4. like we did this for like 10 years in
the movie setting this infinity saga up
they were mcguffins for a long time
we're not going to go right back to that
but here's the problem they ran into
with the what if tv series so the whole
idea is that animation takes way longer
than live action so for example there
are just a lot of twists that they used
on the loki series that they didn't
write till after they'd already started
working on the what if episodes and
decided what the plot of what if was
going to be so they'd already committed
to ultron wielding a version of the
infinity stones before the loki writers
wrote that big twist with the infinity
stones had they known that they probably
would have added some extra explainers
to the what-if episodes to explain how
it is that ultron is able to use these
infinity stones in different realities
so if it seems like a continuity issue
and it just doesn't totally make sense
based on what you've seen in the marvel
movies so far or if you're a longtime
comic book reader what you've read in
the comics it's just a result of the
practical problems that they run into
trying to do animation and weaving that
in with the continuity of the
live-action stuff because it takes so
much longer to do animation and even
though the show is meant to be canon
because it's animation i think they're a
little more forgiving with the actual
continuity of the series itself most of
those small things don't bother me
because for example going into what if
season two ultron with all six infinity
stones is not going to be the big bad
again it'll be some other big threat and
i know you all have questions about how
they're going to weave in with the plot
of kang and the multiverse war because
that's like the big thing during marvel
phase 4 right now but because what if
got started before they decided that
kang was going to be one of the main
villains of marvel phase 4 that's why
you don't see him anywhere on the series
ant-man 3 quantum mania hadn't happened
the loki series hadn't happened so they
couldn't do kang yet they didn't know
that they were going to do kang on loki
and they didn't know the main version of
kang the conqueror of the mcu the true
kang the conqueror was going to be the
main villain of ant-man 3 yet the reason
why they don't really run into these
issues with a lot of the live-action
disney plus series or the marvel movies
is because the plot of each of them is
so different and if they have crossover
moments it's really just like a
post-credits scene whereas what if is a
multiverse series trading out a lot of
the same tropes as the loki's series so
they were bound to be all kinds of minor
continuity issues but at the end of
episode 8 ultron almost winds up killing
the watcher uwatu who slinks off back to
the universe where dark doctor strange
has holed himself up in that special
magical bubble meant to protect him from
the destruction of his universe so right
now the space inside that protective
bubble is the only bit of his universe
that is left that's another one of the
rules that they're kind of crazy on like
you would think that his doctor strange
would be able to travel into another
dimension if our doctor strange from the
mcu like maine benedict cumberbatch
doctor strange from the live-action
movies has been able to travel to other
dimensions also he still has the time
stone so are we gonna have a situation
where you have multiple versions of the
infinity stones in the finale against
each other like i said another minor
continuity issue going on even during
avengers end game when there were
multiple different infinity gauntlets
flying around it was the same six
infinity stones just being passed
between two different gauntlets but now
dark doctor strange and the watcher are
going to go around to the different
universes from the previous episodes
that we saw to recruit all the main
heroes from each universe to become part
of their big multiverse avengers team
but part of this when they go to each of
the different characters in the finale
is them showing you what happened next
in each of the episodes like what
happens with shuri and pepper potts
teaming up with adora melange to fight
killmonger black panther in their
universe what happened with ego the
living planet inside the t'challa
star-lord universe when he met his
version of peter quill to enact his plan
to terraform their universe into more
extensions of his body what happened
with captain carter because it seems
like more time has progressed in her
timeline of present day she's wearing
the winter soldier stealth version of
her captain britain looking costume
implying that in her universe they've
had something akin to their own version
of the hydra winter soldier storyline
from that movie they'll show you what
happened next with the zombie version of
thanos and his zombie infinity gauntlet
spider-man black panther head in a jar
ant-man also coming back from that
episode to be part of the guardians of
the multiverse team and a lot of you are
now asking where did this version of
gamora come from which universe because
we haven't seen her wearing thanos armor
yet i believe that she probably came
from the deleted iron man episode that
the showrunner talked about the one
where iron man went to zakar instead of
the hul during the plot of thor ragnarok
had they done his episode i think that
that version of iron man from the
special sakar episode would have
probably survived and come back for the
finale though i think they confirmed
that they were gonna push that episode
into season two though so they might
change it just a little bit because
they're already using this version of
gamora or they may have changed where
she came from but then you see the
footage of party thor meeting with dark
doctor strange talking about zombies oh
zombies i get it now that's also where
the other footage of party thor is like
wait slow down not everybody understands
i understand me i totally get everything
that you're talking about here with the
multiverse you see him fighting ultron's
army inside his version of vegas we
don't know exactly which planet the
final battle is going to take place on
but eventually they will rally on the
same planet and the whole idea is that
they'll use black widow from this
reality from ultron's original reality
with arnhem zola's backup inside the
ultron robot to disable ultron long
enough or at least slow him down long
enough for them to destroy his body and
take the infinity stones from him
because that's really all they need to
do once you take the infinity stones
from him he's just regular ultron again
we'll see if the watcher winds up fixing
any of the fubar universes that he pulls
the heroes from because a couple of the
universes did completely get tanked like
dark doctor strange's universe doesn't
even exist anymore but black widow for
instance when they take the infinity
stones back she could go back to her
universe with the infinity stones and
either snap them or have someone else
who's more powerful snapped them in
reverse all the damage that ultron did
to their reality the only character that
they've absolutely confirmed will come
back in season two is captain carter but
there might be a couple other characters
that come back as part of this
multiverse avengers team i think the
idea though is that they'll cycle the
roster season to season so we'll see
completely different characters during
season 2 for the most part they didn't
confirm what all the episodes of season
2 will be but they did say that they
would start incorporating the plots and
the characters from the brand new movies
so you see shangshi characters
eventually you'll see eternals
characters show up and what if we'll see
versions of kang show up on what if
eventually if you have any big questions
about what's going on with the finale or
what if season two or even the hawkeye
series or stuff that's coming up just
leave them in the comments below and
i'll add that to my future videos my
venom post credit scene video will post
later tonight because the movie's out
make sure you go see it when you have a
chance i've got a full breakdown video
easter eggs for that that'll also post
this weekend everyone click here for my
full what if episode 8 video in easter
eggs and click here for my brand new
spider-man no way home trailer video for
all the tobey maguire and andrew
garfield easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and i'll
see you guys in the next one
[Music]